bienvenidos de nuevo estamos en el
problema número 17 y cómo te das cuenta
ya me tomé el tiempo de dibujar la
figura que está en este problema de tal
manera que no tengas que estar sufriendo
en lo que yo dibujo esta figura que
tenemos a continuación y bueno el
problema me dice lo siguiente la figura
siguiente tiene dos bases paralelas es
decir esta base y esta base y además
tiene 18 aristas las podemos contar aquí
abajo hay 6 porque tenemos un hexágono
aquí arriba también hay 6 porque tenemos
un hexágono y aquí van 1 2 3 4 5 6 es
decir 6 + 6 + 6 son 18 tengo 18 aristas
en esta figura que está a continuación y
los segmentos directos de línea nos
conectan el vértice b con cada uno de
los restantes 11 vértices aquí tenemos
el vértice b y además tenemos 11
restantes
y déjame ponerlo con un color llamativo
voy a guardar este de aquí y además
tendremos 11
vértices restantes aquí tengo 12 aquí
tengo 34 por aquí tengo el 5 el 6 el
séptimo octavo noveno décimo y onceavo
tengo once veces restantes además de mi
vértice ve y nos dicen que los segmentos
directos de línea conectan al vértice b
con algunos de estos versos restantes
muy bien cuántos de estos segmentos no
existen como arista de esta figura no
existen como arista de esta figura
ok date cuenta de lo siguiente aquí en
mmmm ya tengo una lista que conecta a
este vértice con este vértice ven tengo
esta lista de aquí
sin embargo por ejemplo si yo me tomo
este no hay una arista directa que me
conecte albert se ve con este vértice
que tenemos aquí por lo tanto esta nueva
arista que me conecta albert se ve con
este nuevo que tenemos aquí sería uno de
estos famosos segmentos directos de
línea este es un segmento directo
línea porque me conecta a albert se ven
con otro vértice y en este caso este
segmento de lineal no está en esta
figura así que vamos a contar cuáles son
los que no están en esta figura para
esto fíjate que el vértice b se conecta
primero con este vértice con este
vértice pero con este no se conecta de
forma directa así que vamos a agregar
aquí agregue uno este tampoco así que
voy a agregar dos y este tampoco así que
voy a agregar tres por lo tanto de la
parte de arriba de los vértices que
tengo arriba tengo tres vértices cuyos
segmentos directos de lydia no estaban
en la gráfica original los acabo de
agregar te diste cuenta por lo tanto
estos segmentos no existían en esta
figura estos tres segmentos directos no
existían en esta figura y ahora vamos a
sumarle los segmentos que no existen en
esta figura que me cuenten el bcv con
los vértices que también tengo aquí
abajo
por ejemplo el vértice bs conecta con
este punto de aquí pero no se conecta
con este vértice de kim entonces voy a
agregar lo agrego a éste
tampoco se conecta con este punto de kim
así que lo voy a agregar tampoco se
conecta con este punto de aquí así que
también lo voy a agregar con este
tampoco así que lo voy a agregar y con
este con este tampoco por lo tanto
también lo voy a agregar es decir que
todas las aristas que estoy agregando a
continuación no estaban en el gráfico
original y ahora sí con estas nuevas
aristas acabo de conectar al vértice b
con todos los vértices restantes de una
manera directa cuantas aristas agregué
en la parte de abajo
tengo una dos tres cuatro o cinco tengo
cinco aristas nuevas por lo tanto los
nuevos segmentos que acabo de agregar en
esta figura son tres más cinco de los
cuales ocho son los segmentos que no
existían en el figura original y como
los acaba de agregar son los segmentos
que no existían antes en esta gráfica
por lo tanto mi respuesta es 8 ahora
bien también hay otra forma de ver este
mismo problema aún déjame ver si puedo
borrar todas las aristas que acabo de
hacer déjame borrar todo esto todo esto
de aquí volveremos volveremos volveremos
volvemos con remos volvemos date cuenta
que en un inicio el vértice b está
conectado con tres vértices está
conectado con este vértice de aquí
déjame ponerlo con otro color está
conectado con este vértice de aquí con
este vértice de kim y también cuando
esté verse de aquí y con todos los demás
vértices no están conectados porque del
verde se ven solamente salen tres
aristas sale una lista que va a este
vértice sale otra arista que va a este
vértice y por último sale otra lista que
va a este vértice por lo tanto sin
contar a ver teníamos 11 vértices 11
vértices distintos de b son todos estos
pero me llega a tres vértices entonces
si quitamos estos 11 vértices todos los
demás vértices a los cuales llegaban es
decir menos 3 esto me va a dar del
resultado 8 son 82 veces que no están
conectados con ver de manera directa así
que si nos tomamos todas las conexiones
con el vértice se ve de manera directa
entonces estaríamos agregando 8 nuevas
aristas que son las que no están en esta
gráfica cuál
pues que agregué hace rato es decir esta
de aquí esta de aquí esta de aquí estará
acá también está de acá también está de
cam también esta década también estará
acá todas estas ocho son las que nos
faltan para agregar para que el vértice
b estuviera conectado de manera directa
con todos los demás vértices de esta
misma gráfica o figura que tenemos aquí
así que mi respuesta es 11 menos 3 813
más 5 que soy ya está aquí bueno pues
vamos a resolver el siguiente problema
el problema número 17 y para eso de que
me borra la pantalla ponemos todo esto
de aquí y vamos a hacer el problema
número 18 18 y tenemos también una
gráfica así que déjenme hacer de la
gráfica de a continuación la gráfica
siguiente para esto déjame tomar a un
plano cartesiano tengo por aquí ni tengo
por acá
x tengo por acá mi eje x vamos a
ponerles nombres este es el eje y este
de aquí es el eje x y tengo un cuadrado
de hecho es un rectángulo un rectángulo
parecido a éste un rectángulo parecido a
éste un rectángulo parecido a éste ok y
qué puntos me dan bueno me dicen que
este de aquí este es el punto c déjame
cambiar del color para que lo veas bien
este de aquí es el punto sé que por
cierto tiene como coordenadas un medio
como hacer un medio com hace después me
dan este otro punto de aquí este que se
llama b y tiene como coordenadas menos
un medio como mabe menos un medio como
ven
tenemos también este de aquí este de
aquí se llama am
y tiene como coordenadas menos un medio
como amd y tenemos este otro punto de
aquí que se llama a veces de ley tiene
como coordenadas un medio coma
ok además de eso nos dicen que por aquí
pasa una función muy parecida a ésta va
por aquí sube por acá llega a este punto
de aquí agarra y después vuelve a subir
por acá vamos bien y después sube por
acá hasta llegar a este punto y sale ok
tengo una función muy parecida a ésta
que por cierto se parece a una función
cúbica y el problema me dice lo
siguiente en el plano cartesiano
siguiente a bs d es un rectángulo y los
puntos a s
son puntos en donde se intersecta el
rectángulo con la función y es igual a
pp por equis cúbica james es igual a pe
por equis ubican ok donde p es una
constante si el área del rectángulo abs
de el área de este rectángulo es 4
cuánto vale
p cuánto vale p lo que queremos saber es
cuánto vale p así que voy a preguntarlo
por aquí ok y me dicen que el área de
este rectángulo vale 4
podemos saber cuánto vale su base cuánto
vale esta base de aquí hasta acá cuántos
este valor
bueno pues de que acá hay un médium y de
aquí acá también hay un medio porque de
este punto de este punto aquí cuando x
vale 0 nos movemos para acá una
distancia de un medio para llegar al
punto menos un médium nos movemos
también una distancia de un medio porque
llegamos al punto un medio coma de por
lo tanto la distancia total que hay de
aquí a camps es un medio más un medio es
decir una unidad completa una unidad
completa si el área de este rectángulo
vale 4 y esta base vale 1 entonces
cuánto debe depender esta altura bueno
pues el área el área es lo mismo que
base por altura pero el área vale 4 a
lavarse vale 1 entonces la altura debe
de valer a por la altura la altura debe
de valer 4 es decir que de aquí a camps
hay 4 unidades ahora podemos decir que
de aquí para acá hay 2 y de aquí para
acá hay 2
es decir que este rectángulo tiene como
centro el origen
dicho de otra manera es simétrico bajo
el eje de las equis podemos asegurar eso
y habrá forma de hacerlo creo que sí sí
sí claro si nosotros nos fijamos en la
función y es igual a pp por equis cúbica
es decir esta función que tengo aquí
estás acá es una función simétrica si
nosotros conocemos las funciones cúbicas
siempre de una función cúbica pase por
el origen es una función simétrica es
decir lo mismo que pase de aquí acá es
lo mismo que tiene que pasar de aquí acá
como es una función pública entonces el
mismo recorrido que hay de aquí hasta
acá es el mismo recorrido que debe de
haber de aquí hasta acá por lo tanto
esta distancia y esta distancia deben de
ser iguales esta instancia y esta
distancia deben ser iguales o dicho otra
manera esta distancia debe de ser 2 esta
distancia debe ser 2 y ésta también debe
de ser 2 porque la distancia de aquí
hasta que toda esta distancia son cuatro
unidades es decir la altura de este
rectángulo y creo que ya estamos muy
cerca del final porque porque entonces
ya sé cuánto vale este punto este punto
de aquí el punto ce ya puede saber sus
coordenadas de una manera perfecta tiene
como coordenadas un medio en x pero la
altura que subimos a partir de aquí son
dos unidades es decir que de aquí a acá
hay dos unidades por lo tanto estamos en
el punto un medio coma dos un medio dos
y está genial esto porque ya sé cuánto
vale el punto cero pero el punto c es un
punto bastante especial porque es un
punto que cumple que es la intersección
del rectángulo con esta función que
tenemos aquí es decir que este punto
está tanto en el rectángulo como en la
función por lo tanto yo puedo decir que
cuando llévale 2 cuando llévale 2
entonces x vale un medio en esta función
x vale un medio 2 es igual a p lo que
queremos saber es p por equis elevado al
cubo
pero x en este punto vale un medio por
un medio elevado al cubo perfecto y de
aquí ya tengo una ecuación en donde es
muy fácil despejar ap-2 es decir el
valor de y en este punto es exactamente
lo mismo que p por un octavo por un
octavo o dicho de otra manera
p es igual a 8 por 2 lo cual es 16 p
vale 16 que es justo lo que yo quiere
obtener 16 es el valor de p porque
nosotros obtuvimos el valor del peso
sustituyendo la equis y la jem de este
punto de este punto que estaba en esta
función ojo lo importante de este
problema fue sacar esta altura sacamos
esa altura dándonos cuenta que es un
rectángulo regular que está centrado en
el origen es decir que la distancia que
hay de que acá es la misma distancia que
hay aquí a camps gracias a la función
james igual a pp por equis cúbica y
entonces obtuvimos este punto cm y una
vez que obtuvimos este punto se
sustituimos el valor de xy de y en esta
función para aquí puedes despejar
y ya está y creo que son todos los
problemas de esta sección
cuando esto acabo en la sección número 4
del examen número 4 así que nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo donde vamos a ver una
sección nueva hasta la próxima